hey little girl is your daddy home need
to go and leave you all alone we have
a I'm good to you did he buy you we're
waiting on you yeah I'm working this out
I'm trying to get into the rehearsal you
think what I do is easy you think I just
open my mouth and babble like a baboom
no the oh my god when you die they
should give your brain to research here
we
go I think research should take my brain
long before I die it's not helping me
out any look this was all good stuff and
we didn't record it cuz recording we are
recording we got this keep this in for
the uh when this is all in this is all
in yeah listen we were getting ready to
record an episode of going Bri needs a
friend but I started babbling and I was
doing some kind of song here girl is day
at home need to go did I was I doing
that you were yeah yeah I don't know if
we can clear that do we have to clear it
or is that not matter on the podcast
your version of it is so far removed
from home go leave you all alone yeah
mine is sort of like a ho down
Springsteen mhm yeah it's weird now that
you said it we probably can't clear it I
I don't think you can I don't think you
can just saying fine let's start again
no you can't I'm telling you under eight
seconds we're fine you just described my
wedding night oh Bo yay the funniest
joke in the world was just told by Conan
O'Brien and now it's a song now it's a
song and now it's a
rap
okay let's stop that beatboxing is the
best right was that what that was that
was his no that was me having I thought
there was a Le cloth dryer somewhere
that was anaphylactic shock that was not
many times I've had an adverse reaction
uh to like a peanut butter that I was
supposed to eat and I start
going and people gather around me and
start rapping is that what that well
what what is what would it sound like if
you tried to beat
box oh so the exact same thing okay yeah
I like to do little it sounds and looks
like you're on an iron lung when you do
that but a a high-end iron lung oh for
sure yeah for sure yeah when I had an
when I had an iron lung as a child it
was the Cadillac of iron lungs it was a
really good one does anyone even know
what an iron lung is anymore that we're
talking to we have we have such a
youngan respirator right yeah it was a
giant box they put you in that helped
you breathe back long before there was a
real respirator but it looked like you
were encased in a giant I don't know it
looked like an old boiler there's one in
the big Labowski oh okay there you go
well then people do know what it is
because everyone people know what the
big Labowski is anymore I don't know
we've got to make sure our references
are cool cool and up to date that's what
we have to make sure people know the big
Labowski that's how that's what I
learned when I learned what a White
Russian was yeah like how it's okay how
it's made it's made with kala it's made
with Kua and then you met your husband
yeah what what huh a White Russian what
oh oh my God he is Russian and he's he's
a Soviet he's not a Russian what's the
difference yeah really what do you mean
what's the difference that the Soviet
Union was a lot of different countries
and so people from like you know mova
aren't Russian they're Soviets I
understand that does he consider himself
by the way this intro is all over the
map we're beatboxing we're talking about
the breakup of the former Soviet Union
iron lungs iron lungs this is a mess of
an intro and I love it yeah it's good
this is uh the Jackson poock of podcast
intros it's just a bunch of splatter on
a canvas did you even start the podcast
did you say what the podcast was oh if
people are listening to this and don't
know what it is them well they've
also serious and you did they downloaded
and my face is on it and if someone's
going what is this Conan hasn't
properly prepared me for what I'm about
to hear now we're talking here he goes
this is what I've been trying to get you
to be first of all what is
Conan is he that that scallywag that
replaced Hamin in 93 cuz I won't have it
second of all what's a
podcast where's Walter
kronite I'm upset where's my photograph
needle well this is Con Brian moment the
con B needs a fan blah blah
blah Jesus great I love this this the
way all the intros should
or stuff I just want to know how that
guy even found the podcast I mean I
don't get it okay no no it's like one of
his grandchildren got into his stuts
Bearcat and and they just had Bluetooth
put in it and he was like he got it to
the front and turned the crank and fired
it up and he got in and he heard me
babbling about iron lungs oh I remember
having one of those as a child they have
a stuts bearcat with Bluetooth yeah oh
I'm saying his grandson put it in his
grandson installed it yeah okay and he's
like what is this tooth of blue whose
voice am I hearing what an irritable
woman she is papa papa grandpaa that's
Conan this is a podcast for listening
to well I'll take you for a ride because
it's Sunday and that is our tradition
but listening to this man is just
terrible if he is indeed a
man hug chuga hug now remember you'll
get a lot of inherited wealth and then
you'll go to the ivy cool I declare yes
grandfather oh here he
is a hard right turn kid falls
out oh no don't worry there are seven
more of those back at the
estate good thing we real
breeders anyway uh if you can decipher
this intro good luck to you cuz I sure
can't what a what a bag of mush that was
and yet indicative of the quality of
this podcast overall yes exactly we've
caught lightning in a bottle a man
freestyling with his two Chums who add
up to 8% I'm telling you with the three
of us well that's a lot when you think
about generous that is generous no I no
but gorley is a solid six oh I'm only 2%
of it I think in the state of this intro
this is a compliment meaning we're not
contributing to this absolute hor
you know what I
mean when the episodes are good you guys
are contributing like 70% uhhuh yeah uh
all right well we should get going and
again uh very interested for fans to
diagram what just happened in this intro
charts flowcharts diagrams oh yeah and
also things where you have photographs
and there's yarn connecting them when
you're looking for a serial killer yeah
do that with this intro cuz good Lord I
don't know what
happened